the biggest release we've ever done for
hazel is now out
it's now available it's now over nine
months of work 420 something thousand
lines of code added an amazing team and
Community lots of work later
hazel2023.1 is now out the very first
thing I want to do is thank all of the
supporters who helped make this happen
without your support on patreon none of
this would be possible and I would still
probably be working on frostbite at EA
so what exactly does it mean when I say
that we've released Hazel or we've made
a Hazel release basically what this
means is that we've merged from our
development branch called Dev into
Master which is kind of like our release
Branch this branch of Hazel is kind of
like this stable version of Hazel that
is not currently kind of in development
it's been thoroughly QA tested and it
should mostly work apart from of course
the occasional bug here and there as you
get with all software so a lot of these
features that I'm talking about here
have been around for a while and we've
even shipped games with them but now
they are finally kind of properly tested
fixed stable and merged into Master
right so in this video I just wanted to
go through through all of the major
features that we've added in this
release there are quite a lot as you can
see here from the release notes which by
the way are on our brand new Hazel
documentation website
docs.hazalounger.com has a bunch of new
features Tim has been working very hard
on that aside from listing all of the
new features and changes and Bug fixes
inside the latest release Tim has also
put together an amazing tutorial on
creating your first game in Hazel so if
you are a patron if you have access to
Hazel you can just get this latest
release of Hazel and follow along with
this tutorial and you will make this
game and also learn how to build it for
the run time and package it into an
actual Standalone application which is
really cool and now let's get into some
of the major new features that we have
so the first thing that I wanted to talk
about was multi-threading I kind of
talked about this in a dedicated video
in a way I didn't go too in depth in it
I'll have that linked up there if you
want to check it out but basically
Hazel's runtime now runs on two threads
there's a main thread and there is a
render thread now this theoretically up
to doubles the performance on the CPU
side of things of course that depends on
what kind of game you've made and what
it's actually doing but it's a really
nice and welcome performance boost the
other huge major new feature is asset
packing or asset packaging which
basically refers to the fact that you
can now actually build all of your
assets and scenes and everything that
kind of makes up your project into
something called an asset pack I
actually kind of worked on this feature
a lot during last a lot of dare that we
did let them dare 51 where we made
dichotomy and we actually shipped with
these two major new features
multi-threading and asset packing even
though they were kind of I guess in a
beta State because of course they're
only going into the release now it still
let us kind of distribute it and test it
and make sure it's stable before we kind
of committed to creating an actual
release okay the next feature is sound
graphs this is courtesy of Jay who is
our kind of volunteer audio developer
who's very passionate about audio and UI
because not only has he made this
beautiful sound graph system he's also
made all of the UI for us this kind of
node graph UI you see here is all thanks
to Jay I'm not going to get too deep
into the specifics of sound graphs here
but I will say that this sound graph on
screen produces this audio result
foreign
and I even had a go at making a sound
that we use in dichotomy using a sound
graph for last lavender as well which
was fun okay next up we have better
gizmos we added like in fact the whole
kind of concept of multi-selection is
something that is quite new so you can
see that we can kind of select multiple
entities at once here and apply
different transformations to them we can
also change this multi-transform Target
to pick for example like what point
things are rotated around if it should
be like the center of all the objects or
the individual Origins so that's
definitely a good Improvement and very
handy depth of field is something that I
added I don't know like six eight months
ago quite a while ago to be honest you
can see it here in this like little
depth of field test scene where we just
have a focus Target that's programmed to
kind of change the depth of field effect
Focus from net afar as it moves and it's
it's quite a nice effect like you can
see here during the development of
dichotomy I made this like nice piece of
art here to highlight some of the cool
kind of graphics features that Hazel has
a spotlight lights have also been around
for quite a while this is only the Karim
added they have basically all the
properties you would expect you can
change like the cone and the attenuation
and the intensity all that kind of stuff
as well as like the color and we also
have the ability to make one Spotlight
at the moment be Shadow casting we
haven't really expanded this to multiple
spotlights but that is something that
will come in the future and you can see
a spotlight with shadows here being used
as part of our kind of Animation test
scene that Tim put together all right 2D
Sprite rendering this is something that
has also been around for a while but we
finally kind of had the time to actually
polish the workflow for this so there's
a Sprite render of component as you can
see and you can just place around 2D
Graphics here that do not go through
like the standard 3D rendering pipeline
so here it's actually used to create
this UI that you can see for our kind of
Space Invaders clone the server is not
running at the moment which is why it's
not loading the scores but these kind of
UI elements aside from the text is
created using that Sprite renderer we
also have a debug renderer that you can
actually use from c-sharp I use this
back in my how Ray casting and sphere
Works video that's part of the ray
tracing series you can see that on
screen here just basically calling
debugger android.drawline from c-sharp
along with Hazel's really fast kind of
iteration time for C sharp scripts you
just hit Ctrl shift B to build it
instantly reloads it while the scene is
playing like this you can see it was
really easy to kind of demonstrate and
visualize how like in this case
raycasting and Ray tracing works and in
general the debugger render is very
useful of course for just debugging
stuff while you're making your game and
finally here is a collection of editor
UI improvements that we've made so you
can now create scripts through the
actual editor and then have that be open
in Visual Studio which is quite useful
it'll automatically kind of set up an
entity template as you can see as well
which just makes the process a little
bit faster Tim has also gone ahead and
remade like all of the icons for the
editor basically so this is what the
content browser icons used to look like
we had a lot of these kind of uh default
icon where an icon wasn't made for a
particular type and now you can see they
all look very nice now for the content
browser specifically I did actually work
on thumbnails for it a while ago which
didn't make it to this release so that
will come in a future release where you
can basically just see like the images
actually appear in like the prefabs and
the meshes will actually kind of like
you'll see the thumbnail for them you
guys know what thumbnails are uh same
kind of situation for the components
they used to just be like boxes now they
have actual icons and lots of other
stuff here and there as well and here's
also the editor console which used to
look kind of bland and now kind of looks
better now as I mentioned there is lots
more you can go to docs.hazalender.com
and look at the release notes yourself
and just see like everything that's
included in this release so hopefully
you guys enjoy these new features for
those of you who do use Hazel or like to
learn from Hazel we're going to try and
do these releases quarterly hopefully
and we'll definitely be doing another
release before the next let them dare
game Jam since we want to obviously use
a stable version of Hazel for that game
Jam huge thank you to everyone again for
your amazing support patreon.com is how
you can support this project and get
access to all the source code and Hazel
itself go ahead give it a try report any
bugs that you find and if any of this
kind of stuff I've covered today pitch
your interest you want to know more
about it leave a comment below and I'll
try and provide some more information
thank you guys again goodbye